thank you this is love
okay first of all I want to thank the
organizers that divided us here with the
winners of NASA space of challenge
Orlando to come here and present or
experience with this event as you can
see I kind of I changed the title
because at the end everything that these
NASA programs intend to do is to
motivate citizen let open data
innovation and I'm gonna go through some
resources that they publish from 2012 up
until now and events that you can visit
on-site and get involved with the
community so okay little about me I
finished my faculty of computer science
in my hometown Skopje Macedonia if
someone knows where my Saturday's some
101 well that's great
currently I'm finishing my data science
mr. misters at UCF and I've been living
as a space of project for five years
since copious silicon billion this year
in Orlando I've been part of NASA data
routes 2017 I'm a Fulbright Scholar and
obviously space enthusiasts I wanted to
start with this quote and while you're
reading it just imagine that this quote
was published in 2012 right can you
imagine the amount of data that they are
gathering at this moment from their
current active missions so we all know
that the data is increasing the data
volume is increasing and there are many
challenges that NASA is facing even
since 2009 when they publish their open
government plan and I'm gonna go through
some of the actions that they did but
also what I want to highlight with this
presentation is how you particularly can
get involved as a citizen
similarly to the way that I got involved
with so the final way that I can speed
up downloading data to 1,000 times
faster but then the question is can the
can they handle it they figure out okay
we have this
massive amount of data and we don't need
every part of the data so we are going
to pick only the important part of the
data but again what does important data
mean and then there are more challenges
how to specify how to make meaningful
data but also this important data is I
know the picture right it's still huge
right so the challenges is not only data
volume but how to index it how we just
store it how to searches how to transfer
it so all these stuff increases
exponentially with data volume so for
example the climate change data
repository size that they currently have
is estimated to increase to 230
petabytes by the end of 2030
so in comparison all letters delivered
by US Postal Service in only one year is
equivalent to five petabytes so what
they did was they introduced the open
government plan and this was in 2009 but
what they lack in the first version was
this part and then in version 2.0 they
said okay we will have two goals the
first goal is we are going to find
opportunities how we can enhance the
exploitation of these data that we
currently have but also we want to
encourage citizens to utilize these
datasets that we have and somehow
indirectly contribute to our missions
and I need to highlight here that
everything they share here is my opinion
is not necess we need to say that okay
so first part online resources I'm going
to go through four platforms the day
publish is part of the open governmental
plan and then I'm gonna go through the
NASA space of challenge and NASA details
program so this was the first open data
portal that they published 2012 you can
search through categories you can view
types I've searched here with Python
there are 18 results not that many but
again there are many others so this is
kind of the main one where you can go
there and find everything they
you you need the more specific ones are
called Nasim and this is basically knots
affiliates and NASA employees initiative
to create open-source projects so
basically you can everyone can use it
but not everyone can contribute to it
you need to be affiliate or employee to
NASA but then again there are the api's
nessam here you can use them in your app
or you can send an api template and just
wait for it to be conferred confirmed
and then edit to the community the most
specific one that i wanted to share is
the earth data nasa and this has been I
think the most interesting one to to be
used from our participants of master
space of challenge so here you can
interactively browse browse full
resolution images and you can see
different categories that you can search
for prom and then you also have a
visualization tool that NASA is
providing so basically you can visualize
data over there or you can just extract
it and exploit it in your own
applications so these are the Olin
resources they initiated the open data
innovation innovator program this is
basically the second step of their plan
to engage citizens into contributing to
this open data citizen innovation so
here they are initiating four different
types of events or programs or
mentorship support and I'm going to
going to cover two of those because I've
been individual involved in those and I
can share a little bit of my experience
with it but you can see these are the
numbers of the data sets and color
repositories and these are the goals
that they intend to achieve there is the
government voice you'll see about that
okay so the first one NASA data notes
this is one semester long program for
this program you don't necessarily need
to be a senior software engineer or like
you can be a coding newbie you can be a
designer whatever if you're just
interested
in contributing to the open data space
you can you can join here which it
attracts the data and new company
newcomers so how it works they give you
monthly challenges and then you work
with NASA experts those monthly
challenges depends on your skill level
in on your interest
so you basically you're building your
own program by working with NASA's data
and us as employees if you want if
you're that kind of person you can also
host community events and then engage
more people to your cause or whatever
you're intending to do here and the best
thing is you can be alumni for life
after 2017 I'm still enjoying the
benefits of being there I work with the
newcomers I worked with the new datasets
all sorts of opportunites the most
important part of this openness
innovator program is the international
space of challenge is the most important
because we dissident they've achieved to
engage the biggest number of
participants so this is basically 48
hours hackathon and participants address
challenges we face on earth and in space
NASA is making these challenges and you
will see in I have one slide how those
challenges looked like so for this event
you can host you can participate in it
you can mentor it or you can sponsor
it's similar despite that pie data so
the thing is for instance in Florida
this year there was only one event in
Orlando and if someone is interested
from here from Miami to join the
community I mean I will be providing the
links at the end and seriously if you
apply for a license to host the event it
will be you know easy to get it
so 2017 in numbers they published 25
challenges 2017 solutions were submitted
we had 25,000 participants in 187 series
for 2018 we still don't have the numbers
but they are bigger
this one's so in in those five years
more than 150-thousand citizens were
engaged and for a community led events
that there is a really big number and
it's not only the u.s. it's the whole
world so who is the program for as I
said people that are enthusiasts people
that want to build their tech skills
build their network if they want to get
active as a citizen senior engineers
designers Colliers enthusiasts I've put
designers twice to deform to be a
designer okay
musician biologist entrepreneur train
engine you can do everything so what
what's the most interesting part is
there is a space up kids version so it's
really interesting to see how they are
contributing to the to the space the
ideas are really really good their
future future work at scientists so this
is one of the challenges that we had
last year
don't forget the can opener so
participants here needed to create their
own application to inform their
communities of a potential kinds of
disaster and you can see here this part
is also published on the page where the
challenge is and they show you examples
of resources that you can particularly
use for this application but again if
you have those links that I've showed
you before the resources you can just
find your own ones not only this ones
that are published here so for instance
this was one of the applications that
are currently competing for finalists on
a global level and they use area project
for natural hazards it is from NASA JPL
Caltech so it's not listed on those
resources but they exploited this data
and their product looks really good but
it's really interesting is that at the
end of this event the ownership of the
code is on the four on the team it's not
NASA's it's not you know what
so finishing with this slide I want to
invite the Florida winners to share
their experience with you for the space
of Orlando so give them applause hey
good morning I'm David Lockett and this
is Eric good we want to talk to a little
bit today about our experience with the
Orlando NASA space apps challenge a very
rewarding experience very positive
experience the name of our project was
called whether to launch it's got a big
meaning behind that very practical use
can be used kind of a across the board
we are one third of this team so we've
got the rest of kind of in tow they're
all still sleeping yes so what we wanted
to work on one of the projects equal
work on was launchers so launches from
NASA private company launches and
there's something that interests us not
only being from Florida but being from
Orlando we're about an hour away from
the Cape so I go and try to watch them
as much as I can something that
interests us though is when you go and
you're sitting in there waiting and it
doesn't launch and you're sitting there
trying to figure out why that's
extremely frustrating you just waste
your all day and they delayed because
the winds are you know 20 miles per hour
and it's their max is 15 so it's just
there's a waste of time so we wanted to
find out if there's a way that we can
sort of predict a little bit of what the
weather is going to be like on the day
of large so we can decide if we want to
go out there so that's where whether to
launch came from so what we were doing
is we were taking api's from weather
websites and we were taking launch data
of what up-and-coming launches to find
out what the wind speeds were going to
be on that day and put it to the
criteria of what NASA's criteria are for
the different rockets we wanted to go
back in history but we actually couldn't
find we found history of launches in the
past but a lot of them didn't have data
on why they were canceled or why they
were delayed I talked into the NASA rep
that we had she said they use
put that information out there we trying
to have to explain why they didn't
launch which I understand but didn't
really help us too much but if we could
get that information we can find a
little bit more of what what we're just
concentrating on whether we would like
to go more into other criterias that
could prevent it from going off but if
we could get a little bit more
information on what weather caused it to
not launch it would help us understand a
little bit more but again it's just it's
something that we thought would be super
useful you can look at it's like going
to the beach you look at the weather
this is 90 percent chance of rain you're
not probably not going to go to the
beach so we wanted to do sort of the
same concept with launches so that was
sort of our concept we did we do have a
website up it's whether to launch calm
there's nothing on there besides like an
intro though data we were collecting it
ran out of money so we're currently
trying to switch it over to firebase
storage and we're working on doing apps
with flutter so that way Apple and
Android users can use it but the
websites up it has our link to our NASA
apps page and as our link to our github
so if you guys want to check out the
code up there but we were going to
happen that's called gages we're going
to gauge that show you the range of
danger of what the wind speeds
thunderstorms in a range one thing we've
found out if a light means they have to
wait at least 45 minutes before they can
even attempt again so if it lightnings
with it I think it was like 15 miles
they have to wait 45 minutes before they
can launch again so that's something
where you can see okay there's a
thunderstorm coming through I'm going to
waste my time driving out there or you
can go and hope hope it goes off so
those are some of the things that we
were we were looking at another one that
was really curious to me was launch
window sometimes the launch windows can
be for hours sometimes they can be
literally we saw one I think it was like
two minutes they have launch window for
two minutes so if it's two minutes a
high risk that something could go wrong
in those two minutes and it's probably
not going on
so that was another factor that we took
in and then some of the data we took
from NASA was just information about the
Rockets if it was a NASA rocket which I
don't think it's a delta and space and
all them but they had information on the
different payloads on the Rockets on the
missions and we linked all that
information on the specific rocket that
was going up and what mission was going
on so and it was going to work with all
over the world - so it takes rockets
from all over not just Florida it's how
we did it we just we use firebase we use
ares weather API and then we used
there's flight I think those launches
library launches library comp or
something like that has an API on all
the up-and-coming libraries oh yeah
there we go
launch library will is close that
library has all it and it's actually a
really good library if you just want to
look at what launches are coming up it
gives you the time gives you all the
good information the window the mission
all the information is really there that
helps you out with that so those are
some of the tools we used Davis got to
talk a little more about experience so
our experience when we came into this
we'd have any idea what would come out
of it you know it was it was a
collaborative process you know we had
some fantastic leaders that guided us
through the process you know we wanted
to think how could we make it
educational how could we make it
available so you know it could be
beneficial to everyone I'm an IT teacher
middle school and in high school you
know when I talk to my students about
this they were amazed they're like wow
you know when can we use this what was
the process behind it and I said lots of
pizza and Red Bull
you know definitely a worthwhile
experience you know something that we
took a lot away from you know we're
working on it now where we're building
you know we look at the total process
and not only what we can learn from it
but you know what we can have others
learn from it you know and make it as
educational as possible it was actually
my first hackathon so you know there's
only six months in the coding so I still
have no clue what I'm doing
but I learned a lot in those 48 hours so
this is a really fun experience don't
try it out and you pretty much can go in
and do whatever you want I plan on doing
this again next year and hopefully
working on this a little bit more maybe
one again yes yes thank you guys
thank you thank you guys keep them in
case you have questions any questions
for any of our speakers
I I may have missed it but happened
there were six on your team how are you
related to each other connected are you
co-workers friends students were you put
together we met that day yes we
literally walked in I think two of them
two people are talking about launches
and I was like oh I like rocket launches
and literally we just all got together
and ended up being the team so it was
fun too I didn't meet the meeting David
he taught me about it showed me a makers
faire he taught me a lot about other
things so it was actually a good
community growing yes good networking
too
how much of this time I guess from your
process of injecting the data how much
of it is do you need to clean it versus
automatically cleanse to import her API
into the system
it was pretty instant a lot of it was
just taken Gerrit the other guy on our
team he was the one put it into fire
days and he was updating it pretty much
instantly we just took what the
information we need it was pretty basic
API so we just got what we needed from
it hi actually I have a question about
this open data so for these kinds of
like earth data they are all connected
like when you actually publish those
data through the website how do you
determine like what's biased API you
know to satisfy the client's needs how
do you organize those connect to the
data like are those weather like an
earth state had connected naturally or
let's say like oops I mean connected I
mean related or something like that
you're asking about the API sir that we
asked about the API when you design the
API I'm asking like how do you design
the API of this program so the thing is
that masters programs they have
different parts of that program and then
citizens you can build your own API and
then just upload it there you don't need
to be to connect the API to something
you can just apply send your API
template to the page but if you want to
use an API that is published there you
can connect it with your video
application it if that's what you're
asking
oh okay okay
uh-huh
uh-huh
basically it's just your work you need
to work through it yeah so well the
weather the weather actually NASA
doesn't have a weather API I only had to
take it from another website but we took
the weather API and we took the launch
library and we created our own API and
it pulled all the information from that
so yeah so we created our own API and
that we took everything from that and
put it into our database okay I have
some sweats for you
you should have asked the question yeah
we've got some free questions I don't
think there's swag that goes with it but
and you can't ask can I get a bag yeah
when you have those risk scores the
meters or whatever was that something
that you just kind of hard-coded
criteria for or did you fit a model per
disking predicting cancellation risk in
no we originally our original plan was
we want to do machine learning and take
past history and put in two criterias
and have it give us a gauge by itself
but we couldn't find the data in the
past of why they were canceled so we
just took the criteria of what NASA says
is for the rocket or whoever is the
criteria for the rocket and then what
the conditions are going to be that day
and then we just made a percentage out
of it anyone else
thank so quick question you guys did
really well you guys Juan but you guys
said you guys were missing a lot of the
previous data now is NASA thinking about
giving them that information or is that
not thing thanks for asking the question
so in particular for this team and other
teams that are part of this program we
tend to collect this information from
their experience and kind of send that
to those people at NASA who kind of make
the decisions for these kinds of stuff
but definitely yeah we really want to
hear the feedback and when I say we I am
as a community leader here but then
there are other structures that decide
on you know these questions so
definitely we're here to listen and
again I guess they need the forecasts
right for the applications we'll see
yeah
the NASA rep though is there she was
actually really interested in idea and
she's actually one of the lead people
that determines if it does go or not
so we asked her personally like how do
you guys determine it and she says
literally somebody just looking at the
weather and saying yeah I guess we
should go so she liked the idea of
having something maybe give them an idea
of how it's going to be so she gave us
some links to get some more information
on weather but they said they won't
release why they won't launch a rocket
so we wanted to actually start
collecting lunch rockets at weren't
launched and launched and compared the
weather to that day so we can have an
idea of what's going to what's not going
during weathers but they won't tell us
why they won't launch it it could be she
said they cannot launch because somebody
didn't show up that day and she
literally said there could be that
somebody that important I didn't show up
and didn't launch but they won't tell us
and it also depends on the contracts you
know SpaceX it's not launching from
there
companies are so it's really depends
yeah
so did you apply this algorithm to
previous launches and did you see it
giving you accurate results yeah we we
actually we had a launch I think it was
the day after we finished ours and it
was pretty accurate as far as the thing
is it was actually the picture we had up
there was a launch from like a airplane
and a drop of rocket and shoot off there
so that one's hard to track us you don't
have a specific location of where it's
being launched it's wherever the plane
is but there is recently a launch I
think like a month ago and they they
delayed it three times because the winds
were above the threshold and and the the
data we were looking at it said it was
in the red it said it's highly unlikely
it was it wasn't gonna go so it is
practical it does work we just need to
get we need to get a better weather API
the best we can get is 14 days forward
so we can only really predict 14 days
before the launch oh so you were you're
your model would be accurate if somebody
looked for it like within a couple of
weeks before the launch
yes yeah and that's why we want to pass
data so we can do it that way but we
just we can't get that information
things
this is weather data you're using right
how extendable is it to say hurricane
prediction you're looking at weather 14
days ahead well we're just using the
weather API it just gives us the
forecast for 14 days so if there's a
hurricane to 14 days it's probably not
going we got one more
I guess on the topic of NASA using it
there's also the feedback loop of if I'm
the person making the go no-go call at
NASA and I know that a lot of people
have gone to the site and are expecting
a yes launch are expecting a no launch
is that going to factor into my decision
what to do based on all those fans out
there I hope they say go because I drove
out there but hopefully they're not I
don't think they're going to be using
ours to make the decision
this was more for it was more for I've
just was super interested because I've
gone out there plenty of times and they
canceled it and that's just really
frustrating but it'd be really cool if
they would use it alright well thanks
again
[Applause]
you
you